So thus far what we have done, is we have
defined the class Movie and then we went ahead and defined
a couple of instances of that class, namely Toy Story and
Avatar. Next, what I want to do is I want to
run a quick little part experiment which is, what do you
think will happen if I remove the keyword self. From in
front of one of the instance variables. So let me just
go ahead and do that right now. There. Now I
want to think about this question. Here is the code for
the class Movie one more time, and this is the self
I'm wanting to remove from in front of storyline. And I
want you to think about this question especially in the context
of running this code, which is print(avatar.storyline). Once you have a
hypothesis, I want you to enter it in this box. After
you've submitted this response, I want you to make this change
on your own computer and see if your hypothesis matches your result.